thanks for being here I am so excited to
be here I'm such a fan and a cozy comedy
nerd um I've been watching you since I'm
a kid okay well that's very nice you
know it's weird we started doing it it
felt like when we were kids you know you
were we were children yeah always
swabbing cool yeah I was an 11 year old
girl when this show started and and then
things happen but it's so funny now to
meet all these people that are just
great really hilarious comedians and
performers like yourself and then they
say yeah I watched you when I was a kid
and I go way and then I remember I'm 88
years old you know I remember Amy
Poehler being like your annoying little
sister she was my sister she played my
sister she was your sister but she had a
crush on me and she wore this giant
headgear energy was insane yes it's nice
to know that you were out there watching
yeah and buying all the merchandise you
know I was very impressed with I mean I
saw this in broad city but I really it
really came to the fore in your stand-up
special you're a very talented physical
comedian you're very physical thank you
is that something it just came naturally
to you I think it did because you can't
invent that that isn't coming back oh
yeah I mean I did like dance and
gymnastics as a kid and I was always
like climbing the bookshelves so I
really I love to like countries yeah I
don't know why you climbed the
bookshelves so that's it cuz that was
sort of the tallest thing in my house
and that was the only way I mean I still
do I hop up on a kitchen counter to grab
a class because I'm short right um but
yeah you know it was it reminds me of
your physical comedy with the frickin
yeah I would always I mean it was
Restless I would always move my body
around in strange ways just to amuse
myself and then when I was a kid my
mother my leg would be going under the
table and I'd be moving around and she
would put her hand on my knee and say
stop it people will think you're an
idiot
[Laughter]
yeah I did that too I would always
people would be like when I was taking
tests like bobbing my leg and I remember
getting a lot of can you stop and I'm
like I have anxiety I don't have to tell
you sorry
yeah well it feels like you're you're
putting it all to good use now because
in your special you're I mean you're all
over the place it's great I mean you're
you're very fiscal and and I can see
that you really like to inhabit the
stage and move around you're not just
standing there with a microphone sort of
telling you know your material yeah
because there's like different ways to
do stand-up now to incorporate video and
DJs and I'm I'm still kind of bare bones
with it
and I like to at least take up that
space you know it's just being a mic and
it's it's also like when I'm writing
I'll stand up and write a thing over
here and then I'm like figuring
something out and I'll go you know I'll
go right on the floor and I feeI find
the same the same thing that stand up
where it's like oh right the whatever
the Nazis bit happened over here and
then the Nazi [ __ ] did always happen
over here you'll learn that insider to
the left yeah and you know I like that
there's like sort of moments like via
space I like that you you're very good
at going in and out of sort of like
different accents or dialects thank you
like Australian you do a good Australian
accent is that that's a tough one to do
I was there I did a show there I want to
say I don't have was nine months a year
ago and it was I was trying to master
that accent that's an impossible accent
to get you know I I don't know why I I
I'm gonna butcher it now but I find it
quite easy because it's all about the AE
you know you just if you keep a sideways
smile I went there you know my friend my
friend Cody said Stephen laia bein deep
seven-layer bean dip and it I don't know
it just like set me up but the whole
trip I went I did stand-up there two
years ago and it was so far away and
such a long flight that I asked my
husband to join me and make it a trip
so we're there and we couldn't stop
imitating that
it's I'm sighs I'm sorry such would you
do it would you do it to their faces we
tried not to try not to you but it was
like you know like just in moments we'd
be like thank you so much thank you so
much and then we'd walk away and be like
oh my god and I couldn't help it because
I was like gathering all these not the
most attractive accent in the world you
know sound bites all the whole time
leading up to my the stand-up show and I
couldn't help but like share with them I
was like it sounds like you guys don't
quite know what the accent it's supposed
to know Australians go in and out of it
like they're putting all of us on like
no no it's the bathrooms over there
[Music]
sometimes it's like back in the cheeks
and you really hold it in the cheeks you
know of it and I was saying like to them
other times I think it like it fools out
of their mouth and they just have in
America